what's been interesting since Trump
became president is the number of
Republicans who are willing to go out
there and say I disagree with the
President on this the president is wrong
about this Jeff Flake john mccain susan
collins lisa murkowski
all of those people how lindsey graham
at one point marco rubio the other day
they're all willing to come out there
and say I disagree with the President on
issue X Y or Z or he took a wrong
approach to his summit with Putin
unfortunately none of these Republicans
aside from maybe giving a short
interview talking about how bad the
president did are actually willing to
stand up for him Lindsey Graham in the
early days of this administration
happened to be one of the biggest anti
Trump voices in the US Senate and then
he started going golfing with the
president and suddenly his tune changed
I mean it was almost overnight the guy
left the golf course and then started
talking about how great Donald Trump was
but then a few months went by no more
golf invites so he started going after
him a little bit more same thing with
Jeff Flake right Jeff Flake super loud
anti Trump guy and yet 16 different
times at least the Jeff Flake has said I
disagree with the President on this and
we cannot stand for it he's ended up
either backing down or voting or the
specific thing or person that he said
was so awful there is no real never
Trump Republican in Washington DC they
don't actually exist
what does exist is a cabal of
Republicans who understand that some of
them have to face reelection some of
them are ending their careers and don't
want to be looked upon negatively by the
American public either way they're
trying to do two things at once and one
is to give this public face of a person
who's not going to take it a person who
doesn't stand for what Trump stands for
but then we have the very private face
because after all let's let's be
perfectly honest here most Americans
don't go and check the voting records
you might
see it occasionally come up in a
campaign ad so-and-so voted for this
most of it is shrouded in you know
language that paints it one way when in
fact it's another so nobody goes back to
checks the voting records or very few
people do not enough people do that
gives these nevertrump republicans the
clearance to say one thing publicly and
they do a different thing privately and
that is what we're seeing today and it's
not just they won't protect Muller it's
not just that they voted down the
congressional legislation that would
have prevented Donald Trump from
starting this trade war it's not just
that they won't let that interpreter
from that Putin meeting last week come
and testify before Congress it's all of
it these Republicans today have been
given so many opportunities to be heroes
I mean that's what they don't even
understand these guys could have been
the ones to save the day they could have
been the ones calling for that
interpreter from the Putin meaning to
come come to Congress they could have
been the ones to save the jobs that are
being lost now from the trade wars had
they acted but they don't and it's
because they're afraid they've seen
what's happened to Jeff Flake through
Donald Trump's Twitter attacks they've
seen what has happened to John McCain
through the the same Twitter attacks and
all that is his words neither of those
men have actually been punished in any
way by Donald Trump because he can't
actually do it he just goes on Twitter
makes fun of them people in his
administration make fun of them and
that's the end of it but even the threat
of just being made fun of by the
President on Twitter is enough to make
these Republicans completely complicit
with everything that this man has done
the only way to solve this problem is to
vote them out they're not going to come
around they're not going to suddenly
realize oh wait yeah I forgot to do
everything that I said I was going to do
against you it'll never happen
none of these Republicans are ever going
to be the
that we need them to be even though
they've had plenty of opportunity to do
it if they wanted to they could have
done it months ago but every single one
of them failed to do it
I'm fairing cousins and for David Pakman
today we'll be right back today's
program is made possible in part by
better help.com slash Pakman this is
something I really believe in better
help gives you access to fully licensed
and experienced psychologists and
therapists through your phone or
computer I have been talking for years
about the problem around people not
seeking help because of the stigma
around mental health services because of
the cost of mental health services and
all you have to do with better help is
go to better help calm slash Pakman
answer some basic questions you'll be
matched with a therapist that will be
right for you
you can change therapists if you don't
think that it's a good fit it's less
expensive than seeing someone in person
you will still get the professional help
and it is unlimited you can talk to a
therapist every day from home or
wherever you are go to better help calm
slash Pakman it is so easy to sign up
and get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube better help calm slash PA que ma
n if you've been wanting to talk to
somebody but for whatever reason haven't
please go to better help calm slash PA
que ma N